the Union X hold on these will be
vice-president Dean of educational
programs fulfill college here in
Washington DC welcome to the LT Kirby
Center core competencies and citizenship
are be shaped like to say here in the
nation's capital where we hired by Japan
to teach those multiple colleges out
them in all constitutions
we actively do better than one my place
but it's an uphill battle but I would
like to point out is you're going to
Berkeley we must go to the center's are
so I'm very happy this evening to have a
pretty polished and provide here
speaking to us about a subject which we
call it very interested in out some in
the political spectrum are using
technical competencies pass things like
receipt priests occasion which are not
as hard about what we teach but part of
what we do we all know some on college
campuses or the country lovely not ill
bill so we're going to have you ever
never hear our tradition as these events
needs to have one of our students
introduce our speakers wording that nice
country here on the waffles of
internship program which is just
finishing up we're going to have 25
students appeared watching TV training
around cities and places political and
otherwise and all state course the same
time
- of course by me about that
attorney the final paper so be careful
few words
Roger Lane is a junior Global College
majoring in majoring politics history
the involves in Federation Mock Trial
baseball at present system schemes a
currently holding her house on service
committee and just an electric very
recently senior class president will be
personage is holding for that fine
instruction commit evening I don't have
all the Pierre hotel college
particularly on behalf of the 52018 it
is my honor and a privilege do you
here's evening in our album United
Center for Constitutional studies in
position chef here in Newark now so I
have the privilege tonight introduce you
to our senior speaker which Timberlake's
traveled 10,000 study public policy and
international affairs at Princeton
University upon graduation in 1994 she
appears in two positions the Wall Street
Journal where she worked in ruffle and
subsequently and on this cheers to New
York 1999 and thereafter course
for old age where she started to the
features enter Miss chocolate mousse in
have editorial writer for Wall Street
Journal 2005 and it's publicly known for
her weekly column was Tomek launched
which she writes her farmer based here
in Washington DC a 2014 graduate prize
city's miserable and regular
contributors to Sunday's political shows
including the following
CBS Face nation Fox News Sunday Chris
Wallace and NBC's Meet the Press
she's also the author of the
intimidation in how the less profound
things receipts that she's talking to
fermentation disease run is there are
distinct honor to present to you our
guest this evening ladies and gentlemen
thank you all for coming out there
tonight and thank you to Robyn's
professional wonderful introduction and
something incredibly humbling about
knowing that the 19 year old this week's
better than you at age 18 she is the
places you will go
before I talk about the subject it's my
speech I just got word that retail
college and how honored items we have to
cover tonight
I love Philter ecology is a national
treasure one of those best experiences
of my life
couple of years ago I asked to go out
and teach in there every two weeks or so
head Hara right now they're smart kids
I've ever seen in my life
one of the greatest programs in the
country and so again it's just an honor
to be here and be allowed to be briefly
part of the Hillsdale experience I would
like to introduce this topic of free
speech a little story about my children
so for you turns out there we world
understands that you can get a laugh for
those of you who don't practice
Natalija indication of what can happen
of course I have three kids their age
twelve nine and five and they are under
average normal every kid which means
that they exist to avoid each other
why they are on the nurses back the
malls are also our dinner tables only
hazard
and the tall girls would be community
good job this with his Vicryl Center and
she finally grew so frustrated with him
that she turned energy that Oliver we
need stop hockey an important inspired
of volley of complains through shouting
and children yelling you should you
should
and mom desperate stopped by the liquor
store supporters I don't know how long
we all around people and even each take
turns and you can tell me what you think
the definition of three speeches so we
are on the sailors welder of those and
he's my third serious imaginary style an
abbreviated textbook definition of free
speech involve reciting Congress shall
make no laws description of James
Madison is tutorial on millet rice and
warnings about certain sections for
safety public eight mammal another happy
be quite private school feed our
geography the nine year old woman and
she's my rival she's a little child she
convinces nobody never pays attention to
her nobody misses her so she is harmed
as a kid no I know upon the safety or
libel was but then it didn't matter
because group each means there should
never be any restrictions on anybody say
anything anytime anywhere
whatever you want no matter
and she added by the way we should all
start any more tensions what she and
finally his five year old Turner's she's
been watching all this very oddly he was
helping me very hard about what she
would say and she finally fixes her
brother and sister with a very serious
there and she says prestigious even
things wanted one any I was buying
parents and my parents to have those
moments where all falls into place and I
look at my kids and I realize my oldest
positive constitutional conservative my
middle child of the libertarian and
Miami style is that in the cases you're
born in Damascus but I think the bigger
point is the reason I like to tell a
story is because what we have
experienced over the past decade is a
profound shift in our political culture
which is resulted in a significant
portion of our modern politics holding a
fibrils definition of free speech you
can say I like it if I agree with it and
what makes it shifts really notable at
least week is that unlike many changes
in politics you can actually treat back
to one day most times politics things
that are slower you don't really know
when they happen but in this case it is
one day inundated or twenty first two
thousand and that today Supreme Court
assistant United rules and restored
through three types of movies of
American now for nearly hundred years
after that point both sides of political
eyes have used him in - law and by the
way I like to call them speech laws
because that's what they are
if you speech laws to model their blood
levels and multi has little islands in
it the right unit that uses to you as
love did it uses corporations as much
and it does not be blogs and build up
these laws and so we got the mack daddy
of all camping finding these
restrictions which was we can find the
last method temples and the going to
Supreme Court and Court said what you
have gone too far he was violated the
Constitution and five justices rule that
Congress again Nagant you are incited in
the sort of free speech rights of
millions of Americans and that's what
came out of faces United now this ruling
was used very differently on different
sites I've all right
by this point they've got the religions
on free speech and the back of these
campaign finance laws were problematic
from your views and constitutional
conservatives so they knew this rule is
advertised as a blow for free everything
and generally a good day for society was
viewed and unmitigated disaster by the
left because over to that game George
Alexa found that Herbert is harder to
win halls are tuned in and now we rely
more and more on laws simply pushes
political opponents out of the free
speech arena and universe is a pretty
important knocking back all those laws
reopening floodgates for nonprofit
corporations many others who in be free
in public unless
and you have to remember the political
moment at the time because that plated
is the reaction what this was 2010
Democrats are experiencing already
enormous backlash from million policies
in the agenda of the person Barack Obama
there were adults over the auto bailouts
and stimulus spending or Obamacare the
tea party was suddenly in sold sleep and
value the midterm elections that year
Trebek dramatic change in Washington
Democrats
rightfully so in Norfolk electoral
violations we sweep in our congressmen
attention being that the White House in
two years time and here are the Supreme
Court Fang or to let all of our moments
ago speak freely in this election so in
the days to follow the rules and you can
active alert races and I agree with the
book the left the political left can can
actually have a public debate about
causation see and you can create it and
they ultimately decided on a new
strategy and a strategy with this if
they can no longer use the law
barbaracle and seeking election they
would do the next thing
they threatened harassed and intimidated
other participate instead of a message
if you choose to exercise right that the
court now
to you you will pay a political and a
personal price for doing and we see that
strategy on a boulder sense and a
variety of different tactics and in a
very coordinated fashion people who are
engaged in groups again again they
actually to which they us produced
common strategies come up we target none
of this is coincidental random this is
very much part of the playbook by the
political s one of those tactics that we
see out there is the training of federal
agencies on political hopes and of
course best example we have of this is
the iron partisan conservative not
dollars to this day is possible Obama
officials will be Papa sized enterprises
continue to claim that this was just a
couple of employees that systematic euro
the IRS they understand the bond which
is a bonehead error that is the word
presentations on national television
this was just a moment to airfare I will
tell you support lightly that is a lie
we have several investigations Congress
both the Senate and House and we know
general black y'all not all America but
we have everything we do need these
together very very story about what was
going on and hear simple
Supreme Court Citizens United ruling
political s became very concerned when
they saw ha ha we can get the IRS to
shut down from 3 people force you have
in the months leading up to when this
target added and when the midterms
happen democratic corners sunny lines
left to right to the IRS asking them to
target the very groups of the IRS in the
department you have President Allen some
almost every day supporting different
Democratic candidates for Congress say
the same thing every single stop saying
look basic citizens united we have all
these shattering experience who are
rushing into the election you don't know
who they are you might be being awkward
and legally they might be finding life
or an organization he knew that they
weren't it was the Tea Party of groups
like Americans for Prosperity but
exactly what he was doing was blowing
inaudible to the IRS bureaucracy asking
them to step in and because of that
because remember again not only citizens
united on the G+ Facebook Democrats a
very frustrated Federal Election
Commission group that is doing
investigators so when you do turns with
bureaucracy and by the way after opera
feeders highly aware of this old little
session and from ask Lois Lerner we know
preferred email which is one of her top
priority dislike the ideas on profits
operating and election and she ended up
directly after the very first day that
the birthday party for supplier
operation moved to Washington it was
long life higher-ups in DC and the ended
up state rating houses targeting some
400 difference in service nonprofit
groups government in ten thousands of
Americans and effectively silence is
very luxury taken hit their nonprofit
status they couldn't get donors use the
money
it couldn't get people would run perhaps
they went to legitimacy many of them
gave up on the project because we're
just too hard to deal with an IRS to
spending in letters to definitely can go
to jail they want filling up over
paperwork crowd we know you my way I
think there can be no misunderstanding
if this was done so they're working the
dumpling
we know that senior members of the
Treasury Department and this qkf
investigations were aware in early 2012
what was going on and took steps try to
change what was happening because they
knew it was important the liabilities
and yet the area deliberately kept that
information from commerce through the
entire earth 2012 research also had
operations at a 30% election year so
again it was people who were attempting
to get bureaucracy to go after their
opponent itself very consensus is one of
the most egregious abuses of government
power that we have on the books and
whispered in this country
another tactic that we the other proxies
who have used their awesome powers pound
and writing their political funds we've
got another example that's one a more
terrifying example
look what happened was confident John
GoPro
raise your hand you can purchase about
is astonishing there are people who have
observance because this is just it's
egregious when he had their democratic
rights leaders in Milwaukee were a bogus
criminal by the way I expect the word
criminal campaign finance investigation
for about 30 days person groups to which
supported the government reforms a
former governor scott walker wisconsin
had law called the dawn middle law and
allow these prosecutors to conduct this
investigation in secret and the people
who were the target of this
investigation was subject to a gang war
so they were not allowed to tell anybody
that they were these such investigation
they had their findings records hey and
look through their emails pilfered furs
and voicemails hangin there was even
trade conducted on several of their
homes and one case was the target of
this investigation
he is white furniture or fundraising
trip while they are gone their teenage
son was left the home long horses came
in in the early mornings bang in through
the door the question is in a room not
allowed in to call an attorney because
not allowing called the tracker to look
down the road wipes the house all away
whole bunch of computer equipment it at
the end they walk out the doors and you
tell anyone what happened because okay
we only know that all of this positive
because one of the partner to that
investigation a very brave man named
Eric O'Keefe ended up coming to the wolf
internal
telogen story we thought the number of
tourists about it became national news
emissions but it ultimately took a lot
about the speed marche de la Cruz went
all the way up to Wisconsin state
Supreme Court which shut this broke down
and in doing so they're ruling and I'm
paraphrasing a little bit here but they
not lying in a rule in which they said
the prosecutors in this case having been
in serious law in order to go after
citizens who are wholly innocent
property so this term the highest court
the state of Wisconsin a fabulous saying
in a legalistic way so the prosecutors
in this case agenda of this
investigation
entirely frightened and scared or
political bombers that are taking part
in elections environment and the message
again was from those properties if you
dare speak we will turn reliable reviews
and we will potentially even put you in
person we have a more recent example
this and seventeen liberal attorney
general prophecies that are now
launching for over to Exxon and some 100
different conservative version for
Quebec on over years these prompt users
are actually suggesting that they might
bring a racketeering suit against Exxon
for the football crimes leading a long
way on planet we have some cross
litigations on lines of point and some
of you may use and now attitude
and is the tax is catching on across
countries monitored from use your power
to silence or phone another magic we see
out there if you activist group some
corporations free market birds music
blackmail try to silence a speech one of
the Texas attacks and I how about
imposes a group called the American
Legislative Exchange Council this is an
extraordinary group they works without a
free market policy on our model basis
and spread from legislatures and
legislature in state us the nonprofit
largely funded by corporate donations is
wildly set those who long been the
target of the political left but those
perks
once the intimidation games started came
up with a new way of going and what is
in the wage is a very attractive
shooting in 2012 17 euros Trayvon Martin
in Florida they came across the fact
that Alice it had minor role in helping
to spread that model legislation Andrew
Brown law across different states it
ended up being the legal defense that in
learning you in that shooting cake
lesbian activists seized on this they
Brandon Alex racist organizations for
having promoted those immigrant laws and
in the aftermath of the shooting
encourage all of the corporate donors
they threatened to run ad campaigns
Brandon each of those corporate donors
and religious organizations
unless they stop turning our it in
coordinated action Illinois Senator Dick
Durbin to Democrat 10 letters 2000
organizations across the country
community knows they support fellows we
need to know they support Alex Reese's
policies and threatening to hold them up
in front of conferences they said yes
Alex also very active sentences a few
months and we see tactics like this
being replicated in free-market
organizations across countries why we
need to be tactics is important for
people to know they're not these levels
that their organizations are not just
leveled at politicians and levels as
absolutely ordinary Americans who get
into politics one such person is where I
got the book was Manning Brady Anderson
United resistance back in 2012 to a
sizeable donation to the super record
supporting Mitt Romney couple days after
the campaign finance records came out
and left found out that he's given this
money the campaign website for President
Obama's re-election personally called
him at put his name up on the website I
suggested to use herbal work a baton
they were trying to clear Romney donors
or makes weapon in his net not long
after that having mr. Banerjee was
audited by the IRS not one thing he was
visited by the Department of Agriculture
Jesus agenda budget arm flavors system
and never any interaction
prior to the president United States was
in his day on last night and as he said
later he cannot be said this was most
powerful person in the world putting a
target on my back asking people to come
after receiving an average person album
of California back from America from a
campaign in California that ballot
initiative supported provisional America
of traditional marriage mention
Americans in California they believe and
support that ballot initiative activists
were opposed by efficient of comb
through campaign finance records and not
faces everyone if donated money in favor
of cropping their name and their address
they put those into addresses on
searchable lockable maps that they could
go home to home and intimidate service
to be given money the people who have
any illness or said their car keys their
Wizards broken they had their whole
businesses flash mob by protesters or
voicemails and emails for flooded with
threats and insults some of them
actually lost their jobs it will stay
with her to be very much Mozilla there
were
people in Division two n that were no
longer fully after this episode and I
think one of the things that was really
depressing to me later deposition people
were interviewed about this and almost
to alas everyone who targeted on that
list and has something unfortunate
happens M said that wherever actively
again to a ballot initiative they
wouldn't do it which is the source the
other side winning in that campaign one
thing that all of these attacks and back
if you haven't I'm always think about a
lot more deeply is disclosures we in
this country have come associated
transparency and disclosure with his
government but the unfortunate reality
is that artists would disclosure consent
turn on the test the closure is supposed
to be a way for our citizens to keep
track of their government and what's
happening in their government anybody
might you who follows reserved a private
server and today over the last year
we'll know that the back government to
come very very good at hiding his
records from the people and not letting
information out they'd rather not have a
instead result the closures instead
increasingly become a tool by vicious
government and little axis keep track of
their opponents and family our federal
judiciary has received honors from
important presidents that protect and
honoring one of most notable Supreme
Court cases we have is one called
n-double-a-cp sources Alabama and
history offenses work
civil right there there was a turkey
generals in Alabama who's very unhappy
with the n-double-a-cp in the relation
Pete got involved on bus boycott
generally country a lot of problems for
the two governments of Alabama they were
not happy in so they end up the sort of
bonus suit which they claimed the double
ACP was appropriately cooperated in the
state but then and this was revealed
upon they wasn't as judgment said that
was remedies that they wanted with her
the n-double-a-cp have to turn on the
resemblance every more than one
personality
the n-double-a-cp understood that in
wonderful is because the out famine 81
and then maintenance they wanted he was
heading in and over would have been had
now probably in the decorous the idea
was you may be able to karate whether
jobs and perhaps and a spied upon them
remember this was a time in which they
were still shooting firearms voluntary
the instantly see be understood just how
important when they bought this case all
the way to Supreme Court in a union
Supreme Court issued a ruling it were
clear on the First Amendment that not
only go to right to free speech and I
don't think you have the right Fremont
associations of some order to exercise
those words using we have energy and
politics and the supreme one actually
back up a decision with a number of all
throughout the fifty to sixty right up
until nineteen seventies and work and
that's what we got our first campaign
finance law disclosure laws and
besides it'd be better for it to get on
board with disclosure train was
introduced never actually square that
circle it still claims that believes in
double agency versus Alabama and if
somehow this is consistent with all the
disclosure laws we have there the
court's ruling when it first dealt with
the aftermath of the federal election
campaign act Buckley v Valeo justices
major persecution on campaign finance
laws but don't worry if anybody out
there is country field presence you can
just cover this and we will greatly
review well that was a comical back in
the days when campaign finance records
were all sold stored in ten dusty boxes
at the bottom of the Federal Election
Commission of beef in committee you
making donations your name go long and
your address there is on time purport to
offer relief and this is become a
growing problem you had some justices
but if those assumptions take in the
winter time I think we have more agents
that come up to it as an enforcement to
have to be able to inconsistency in the
law but so far this is not something
that has been a priority for the court
and so us all of us to think a little
bit more deeply about some of these
disclosure laws and what they need what
else we do about all because tt very
deserted as we just saw today has
180,000 units left and culture who do to
give a speech at the universe
we have how far importantly at Campbell
it responds to Andrew independent risk
for violence protests among me be clear
those protests were directly or guys to
make sure she never got to say or on our
campuses clear and outright intimidation
of a conservative speaker so I think the
first thing we need to do is just be
aware this happening again it is not
raining the information game is very
very real again as I said in the
workforce dangerous politicians dangers
activist groups that are out there you
look at people to send letters to the
IRS and anything they do something
because people who call the Chamber of
Commerce and run them over the pole in
terms how they spend their money their
donors are going to save others
the same activist groups that are out
there inducing corporate proxy but
trying to pressure companies to pass
proxies that given how politicians Otis
day one through launching using
intimidation tactic to in corporations
upon free marketers so there is
organization out there they know what
they're doing and even have conference
about some stuff and those promises
reach down even into the university
there's an organization out there which
is fun with like unions and
environmental birds called unco my
people they actually go out they put out
a manual a handful to do an active if
you can staff like that process make
sure to give them instructions on how
they can prevent an opposing getting
free market programs might come into
existence on their campus course you
don't have
happened owners are endless Tom Steyer
Stanford firm you know renewable energy
programs that in whatever but this is a
very real thing favors people everywhere
we know who they are and what they're
doing and if we need you rethink and in
very hard about how we limit the power
of the administrative state in an age
which the government is so large which
that administrative state and so much
power over so many aspects of our life
in which they increasingly to our
amusement political decisions we have
very big event at the IRS the IRS we
need to be strict of the ability to make
any political decisions about actors in
election okay any you what the IRS says
that which is to make sure that people
process these and on their eyes on our
taxes and if somebody has complaints
about the actions of a nonprofit
corporation how they engage election
there's very lot of live in Sochi
our Election Commission suspected set up
to be a bipartisan group there are six
members Republicans three Democrats
tapes for them to make movements on any
complaints innocent put in front of them
it's quite a lesson like it because
often it results in stalemate
the NDP isn't nearly as aggressive and
we would like them to be one's come to
campaign finance regulations but this is
feels a fair and honest way to actually
in a common way to have relations issues
about species who the left exercises at
least the members of the federal the
Election Commission are appointed by
apartment and confirmed by the Senate
and get our powers to the people no one
had ever heard was murdered me until
after our machine gun came out and there
was no way to hold her accountable again
she is right now living on full
retirement and pension for several
governors and nothing is enough so we
need to make sure not just the IRS is
there other agencies as well -
Securities Exchange Commission Federal
Communications Commission workers
community health event letters a better
monument but all of em take actions in
recent years as well
it smacks very much political targeting
components that they of life we need to
make sure the bureaucrat you no longer
have that power I think we need to push
corporations to grow some backbones and
to be willing to defend more
aggressively they're very tender right
now too often they read other
organizations or trade organizations to
defendant we should be expecting CEOs to
embrace this right supreme importance
given them and proudly stand up for some
of things they believe Americans than
many of us believe in which is not just
democracy for the paddle is limit attend
to democracy equality I think we do in
fact being is really over all artists
ultraviolet and once again put the onus
of the closure on the government rather
than right now anybody is fourth and
$200 to remember politicians have
deleting their addresses close and I
don't even early
having worked in the sea for a very long
time very no politician in the student
can be bought for two months dollars
give us cops so I think we need to think
about those fresh shoulders you know
what is it one of the better numbers on
Mellanox
maybe $10,000 things you need to think
about whether or not there really is a
risk of corruption in terms of balance
should not disclose the names of people
to give money salaries should we have to
disclose the names people give money for
us meaning those that run that are
simply designed as a public concert
issue rather than to expressly endorsed
a politician or run against their
reelection
those are called expressives and then
they're different that's where there's
potentially a corruption issue in terms
of who's giving money if someone in
London we expect when we return a lot of
different areas but if all the questions
to campaign finance field I'm not
entirely sure there is compelling
reasons for why Adam Janardan beings
need to be out there because again we
have evil they're using disclosure as a
weapon against them I think most
importantly we need to call out
intimidation in any form with any manner
to see if you need to do assistance
there's one thing that I learned from
writing both I interview about 60
different people that involve a target
of abuse like that you know I expected
to go
- and in fact these are just friendly
inspiring people that have all sides in
the solution and then shout down the
people who were imposed people who were
telling them that they couldn't take
part in politics and by March they all
loved that it took some time is not easy
in the end they suffer a lot of slings
and arrows that they were victorious
because we're wanting what we don't
really like to be called out the rather
operate in the shaft and it's a very
good way to make sure that the
Intimidators not today is to not be
intimidated by many the last
conservatives also need to tamp down our
only hope to copy the situation it is a
very easy thing to follow you look at
the other side in some of the battles
the things in the package that they
subject people to I really very good
curtains when Republican is a couple of
years ago
as foundations came into the public
arena and as part of the discussion one
of the first things that a number of how
compelling incentives we should get the
IRS on we should pick the IRS on well we
just went through that
you know how authorities are asked to be
there are ways to look at 20 foundations
that still involved in picking federal
bureaucracy
an organization and we should not be
shared by the way to of competing voices
the service because that we have better
arguments and our family fathers when
they talk about speech or the reboot
they live in it versus in a villa price
they understood that if you had free
free she could not have service and then
what they viewed as the right way the
United States word for word to set
fashion of context those records they
they believe as normal is more to many
more arguments was the way we got a
fuller and better democracy and I think
our society is embraced this calm
champagne wine is was dis on the tactics
of others who receive violence that
cultivate and we over from that you have
one thing to all so much from tonight
[Music]
[Music]
if they will see to it that you and your
colleagues a German person
well I heard lucky and I was born like
in start pureeing back in the head so
this can't iron I don't think you go
into my business unless you are pretty
really been able to take whatever people
can dish out people and you can dial in
like lapis I think when you stand out as
we write about things like that did he
talk about in if you would not believe
yourself some certain courage against we
have the ivy laughing hi nice don't
anybody repeat it sound like Brenna
higher as ought to eat he what IRA about
that in a way of a book like I suppose
but what worries me is that something
some ideas ability uh I'm quite brave
enough come staff here in right away
so people that I worry about my nose
that are not always politically actively
engage and they are the ones who are
very concerned about what the blowback
line kind of happen of communities of
their schools but one of the things that
I think people about this closer that I
think is really really serious that you
don't know how being used against you
you know let's thank you go and
interview for a job and you have a
pretty good first interview
Jericho packages weekend the personal
interview might lift up your political
donation and they didn't want to hire
someone is only very lenient let's say
your kids are really good for exactly
but he doesn't make the part of duty is
it depends a coach lensless
as a cause that your family gives
students they take I mean I have to meet
I had coaches we need to headline the
very end of the season for me to
continue when I get indicated wide and
weighs in the spot but you know people
can find out what you can do a lot of
advertisers are very concerned about
that and it's why we need to create some
of this disclosure so again one thing if
you're giving $50,000 we vary that a
good cause some really smart people I
know that our campaign finance reformers
satellites fragment of the concept who
used to be an MVP Commission Merchants
rhythms that even he would not go so far
to get rid of so high dollar correct
donations politicians between preserving
and corruption element to that and is
your government but really totally would
increase every aspect of the rest of
this coalition protective use scary
people out taking our office
yes I am sure
I wish she did on cultural rules where
does the kind of information people post
Christian society and the religion but
the cultural and often both sides has
been increasing years and the left turns
when there's a precursor to it
and killed the subtitles of a problem
when whose violence in free speech not a
very purpose that I'd say I was
overruled by a Democrat when I select
there is a political left in countries
that sort of in organization almost and
they we know the norm or the power and
that they think his eyes behind the
design new tactics and filter balance in
grassroots and the church and and I
really do believe as I said we speak as
he was gone through the ages and they
have lost the political argument at
least in terms of supports or no main
policies and things that their gold has
been simply stop other people talking
exciting it's very important this up
very much as well
bündchen both Hillary Clinton and Bernie
Sanders promised that was their very
first action if they became elected
president would be to pass an amendment
to change in essence that car they
reported they were in essence saying you
must as impressions of amendment they
won't allow government Society Congress
seat they want to supersede James
Madison and how did that help you
everything you need to know about Alice
a fear speech so business specifically
our attitude so they start that internal
down and then increasingly of people who
say lawyer the final that I have to put
up with this kind of speech anymore and
then you have a reaction on the other
side thing you can't impose and there is
a cultural activist political
correctness which also came out of the
political Buster's won't do if you've
seen reaction to that now people think I
think everyone and you can't stop and I
think what everyone's forgotten along
the way is courtesy simple debate and
conversation we create useful then I
want to go see a college on the subject
and thankfully no we profess to be
surprised me another important soul is
okay but I had a whole moment and she
came which you clearly disagree with the
subject of the top and and she put her
ARVs years ago the first one that's not
Oh God you mean like now there's a
bigger question or I should forgive you
okay
and we should all try to because you me
and half the light civil discourse and
creativity and be courteous of each
other but you're really looking at it
illegal unconstitutional you yes I
absolutely have the right word for peace
and that gets to one other painters
discover not about culture
we need better universities who are
standing up for the rights of free
speech we sell fruits each and every
other advanced country and I think that
that not happen America all until
they're involved and not doing $40,000 a
year and healthier this week so it's on
to campus and a very nature that kids
and violently right ourselves these are
the baton teachers and your fellow
students to be subject for that they're
there to learn and have debate and have
an open society
yes right thanks for speaking tonight
it's a really great presentation I'm
concerned about the impact of social
media let me give you an example I
follow Prager University pretty
routinely they're really a good outfit I
think and they present really good
presentations and what what they're
finding is YouTube is now shutting down
their videos I would like to know your
thoughts about how pervasive this is and
what life's do we have to overcome this
kind of shutting down by by left-leaning
media organizations
[Music]
no because what Brittany Murphy is don't
sign up for our private by the way she
is older person promises while doing no
calculators but surgery is not my dennis
prager out california radio talk shows
PSP marvelously it's really followed by
people who were experts on the subject
seem to be four or five minutes videos
on different area all kind of from a
free market constable conservative
perspective deliberately makes pieces
and the wafers governor's like for
college you to learn about new subjects
to things they might not otherwise do
the university so it has been incredibly
alliance that you to prevent in closing
parental controls on pretty videos 1919
and then less moment are put into these
problems also your parent you've got
ground controls on a computer to kids
cannot access these crazy deals videos
by they are done with kid behind those
and having that why wouldn't they go
having you know anything that would
really be to multi-sensor purple stars
I did a great review video about the
folks and about the threat of silencing
free speech Riverview
centers we had a Newton center so they
sent through my video on for his speech
and so we did four things decided to
call my house going on and resilient
repulse bonded and we do to Rebecca
he was also computer animation you know
compared of it we don't know what
increasingly enough about an hour half
after I call might begin to consult
sentences then one that corresponds to
audience in terms of what when you
visited problems you're not being just
on YouTube obviously face or texted some
conservatives because of concerns about
the way in which certain social media
work incentive to conform I'm not
entirely sure what the introduces in
your private company and I respect the
right front company to do something to
these you something that obviously the
number one option is to not use it that
becomes increasingly in public day and
age where everything is on Twitter and
expose in there in one hour I suppose we
can hope that remaining committed about
this especially some people are trying
to do that I've heard it and I need
going around suggesting the big social
media is to be treated the way broad
asses and subject all kinds of roles and
women's I'm not quite sure to be staying
back here but it is a very learning that
wish I had a better answer moment I
don't argue this is one deliver concerns
outdoors mama yes
I read your articles and content with
heart yeah having fun active no some
babies not only reserves are all up no
accountability but the special
prosecutors of all there are still time
to go after researchers if Supreme Court
shut them down and now the court is
where people play up people week there's
actually been a discussion of whether or
not you get the people who we did in it
we look the whole wonderful report
simply you post again were on people
that you were propagating the
state-level expenses reform that John
the law because it was so egregiously
abuse in this case but that ring does
ánotá means I think we have to take
medicine in the property or a realm in
some way that we do hold some of these
perpetrators of this intimidation
responsible for their ass I mean a most
burner sword is absolutely appalling
because I'll fashion we did have a
resolution subjective issue properties
for giving all testimonies from house
they ascended to it as an attorney when
appointed by Obama he
being the last day before conversion she
does not have gone to the assistant so
there has been no way that hold her
accountable the FBI investigation to
this was the Justice Department benefit
Asian with housing and we have
prosecutors out there who are doing in
Wisconsin what ata was company other
spaces there in Montana legislators lots
of jobs of a similar pony can be -
probably Adams working launch - trivial
appellant ended up kicking him out on an
11-footer mentalism being replicated and
even put pressure on professional life
earns in Bar Association's to look at
projections these people or simply
people look at part of our serving of
federal employee and their rights or an
inner ability to engage in some of this
Oracle prosecution also include some
housing for those our family would have
behaved in a way that law American under
constitutional right yes
thank you for your remarks only via the
message thank you and I rely on baby
power you that now we have opponents and
[Music]
unrestricted Riley and I were elected
what I love a service but I'm very also
change gears a political reality well
then my sermon I do this conservative
need to be very cautious of not turning
around using this using interviews
powerful never signing no I'm here
tending to do so that means that is a
liberal was asking and I have some
certainty a ship USS I would point out
to them not very likely that the federal
government spent under our command
faithful II know tom is going after his
enemies I mean it is much easier in this
is the case for democratic government
when they let women federal bureaucracy
to blow that whistle and get what they
need that it is for a Republican I can
promise you this this president
attempted to get over there are
Christine to do many specially for
whistles arm will be lining up like
outside building the whistle blow on
this tournament it would last more than
35 seconds so I think that's a natural
mark there's a bigger risk Department of
Justice other agencies are very much run
by the political leadership at the top
and have more discretion to focus their
certain types of actions or certain
groups for instance 7,000 deaths essence
of their honorable died and has tried it
one thing again that little setback for
them is that conservatives do believe
that the idea Walker's new employee ID a
constitutional research and and that
works to the left vacant and all these
pages in yes
so all that creature art and the tactics
here you see without reducing our
current events and it all I mean erotic
solvent essentially it's a pleasure to
talk to say complete horoscope so on so
the different recap but the question I
have is what counties are Americans are
are evolved to a level of very street
party many is it a small person engineer
it seems that some machines have to
country competence but it is what your
tech not even if such a high percentage
of US citizens really don't believe in
right and wrong position on what would
probably have a nation under law it
would know right now missions about
actually have amendment for law I would
point out with regard to magic one of
these in turn refers to the book and I
want to often a very strong distinction
here I have no problem with people
protesting things or speaking out that
is part of Ages what parts of a society
and in that fashion versus fashion model
that we fathers believe it and I heard
people saying women disagree I think
what's important about these things
we both that they using federal power
prosecutorial power or other package
design other abuses that's the dividing
line and also tactics that threaten
violence freezes and I have no problem
with Berkeley to going out and
peacefully only designs they have some
fruit of an occult but rioting burning
cars and
turning speakers is not acceptable in
experimentation chemical holding I don't
actually hugely black dress I think you
have a political leadership at the top
and after the first serve all there in
eight years and their second column in a
way that if you need for someone
thinking people like college students to
fall for one of the things you don't
have a life for might be protecting the
one thing was actually encouraging the
above it
I will necessary a big term and sending
this letter out to all the organizations
and support analogy that they come in to
Washington to the council insulting very
hardly leave is that nearly everyone is
his home state papers including local
newspapers condemning they ran authorial
saying you know dirt as enemies list and
this is not appropriate you cannot get
to use the power of you guys and care
organizations that are giving them to
make it limited I think the average
American whether right center left
center they're not committed or partisan
it is the first event and if they're not
under the age of twenty five
they get personal
and understand the importance of free
speech is away people in Serbia public
and that they will rally that nitrogen
being honest and the time conservative
so I am bored and often but I really
really want my important in the time I
sign out there was very heartening that
way and I need to you that as we
practices we can work to also see some
organizations that are getting concerns
about this one but it certainly all a
little less or a conservative writers do
I see organizations like the NAACP
there's one difference realized at one
of the links of all of this horizontal
pieces that they could get turn on them
in the end and a day may relax their
roots of supporting free speech is all
thank you all
[Applause]